as Mídia NINJA is already a self-organizing network,
I'm dedicating myself to another project.
It's called Fluxo, which is Portuguese for "stream."
It's a journalism studio in São Paulo downtown,
where I used livestream to experiment
with what I call post-television formats.
But I'm also trying to come up with ways to finance independent journalism
through a direct relationship with an audience,
with an active audience,
because now I really want to try to make a living
out of my tear gas resolution back then.
But there's something more significant here,
something that I believe is more important and more crucial than my personal example.
I said that livestream could turn the web into a colossal TV network,
but I believe it does something else,
because after watching people using it,
not only to cover things but to express, to organize themselves politically,
I believe livestream can turn cyberspace into a global political arena
where everyone might have a voice,
a proper voice,
because livestream takes the monopoly of the broadcast political discourse,
of the verbal aspect of the political dialogue
out of the mouths of just politicians and political pundits alone,
and it empowers the citizen through this direct and non-mediated power
of exchanging experiences and dialogue,
empowers them to question and to influence authorities
in ways in which we are about to see.
And I believe it does something else that might be even more important,
that the simplicity of the technology can merge objectivity and subjectivity
in a very political way, as I see it,
because it really helps the audience,
the citizen, to see the world through somebody else's eye,
so it helps the citizen to put him- or herself
in other people's place.
And that idea, I think, should be the intention,
should be the goal of any good journalism, any good activism,
but most of all, any good politics.
Thank you very much. It was an honor.
(Applause)